it's time for et's Kardashian ketchup  just want my baby to learn the type of  like Armenian values that like dad  always kind of put onto us growing up  Rob Kardashian reflected on his  relationship with his father the late  Robert Kardashian's senior during  Sunday's Keeping Up with the Kardashians  as Rob prepared to welcome his daughter  he couldn't help but think about his  past this is my first child in a very  special important time to me so I want  to be like my dad meanwhile big sister  Kim was out in LA she attended the daily  front rows 3rd annual fashion los  angeles awards the 36 year old looked at  cereal in a white long-sleeved gimon  sheet gown she also had a fun impromptu  photo shoot with photographer Mert all  US I love that later Kim took to Twitter  to deny reports she was attacked she  tweeted totally not true such weird  rumors  [Music]